جواد ذكريات
في اشخاص
رحلوا عنا وفي اشخاص
اصيبوا ولكن الكلمه بقيت اقوى
والعربيه استمرت اول شيء يعني اسمح لي انه
اخرج عن النص
مكتوب وهيك اقف وانحني عفوا امام بطولاتك
وامام مهنيتك عفوا نحن نفخر فيه او هتطلل
شفناك فيها شيخ الشباب كنت بهالفيديو
فانت بدك تخبرنا
الصحافه
واهميه الكلمه مهما كان الثمن اولا اشكرك
جدا وانت زميلتنا واختنا واستاذتنا
وعزيزتنا واشكر كل الزملاء هو اليوم احنا
نحتفل يعني هو يوم مفرح اكيد
بوجودك
كل الزملاء وتعرفين مسيره العشرين عام
مسيره طويله عمر يعني اللي انولد مع تاسيس
العربيه الان شاب وعنده شوارب ولحيه وربما
متزوجه ابني ما يعرفني يعني تغيرت
واشتعل الرئيس وشيء بلان نقدر نقول يعني
طبعا مسيره طويله
عشرين عام مرت بيها احداث كثيره
عطاء كبير من عدد هائل من الزملاء سواء
اللي يظهرون على الشاشه او اللي خلف
الشاشه
ما من شك انه العربيه هي براند مهم في
عالم الاعلام العربي ومن يعمل في العربيه
نقطه مهمه في السي في انه هو عمل في مؤسسه
رصينه مؤسسه محترفه
مؤسسه مواكبه للاحداث
تتعامل بمهنيه وبعلميه عاليه ومتطوره
ومتجدده متجدده تعرفين قبل 20 سنه الاعلام
ليس كما هو اليوم يعني كان حتى الموبايلات
هذي كنا اذا نريد ننقل لقطه عشر ثواني
لازم ننصب سياره وديش والمهندس يضبط مع
القمر الصناعي الان على الواتساب يوصل
للمحرر وتطلع الخبر بثواني مش من صحفي لا
من مواطن عادي وهذه كانت اهميه العربيه ان
بكل الظروف وبكل الاوقات استطاعت ان تطور
وان تخلق الافكار الجديده حتى تستمر
وتتكامل مع كل الاجيال التي تتابعها الزمن
يمشي وكانه اسرع من الطبيعه واللي ما
يواكب الزمن يبقى بالخلف والناس اللي
بالمقدمه والمؤسسات الجمل للناجحين وليس
للمتنكئين او المتخلفين واعتقد العربيه من
من رواد المتقدمين في عالم الاعلام يعني
احنا نعمل بالعربيه بس هذا واقع يعني
اردنا في هذه الفقره ان نتحدث عن تغطيه
العراق يعني انت تعلم العراق له حيثيته
اكيد
والاحداث اللي مرت عليه كبيره جدا
وانطلقت قناه العربيه مع
الهزمه هزت العالم والشرق الاوسط بدخول
القوات الى بغداد دعنا نتكلم عن التغطيات
وخصوصيتها على ارض العراق
يعني انا اكثر من مره قلتها انه في زمن
يعني في التغطيات العسكريه الحربيه
قد لا يكتفي الصحفي بمهنيته انه كونه صحفي
يجيد الكتابه والتعليق واداره عمليه
التصوير حتى ينجح في ظروف مثل ظروف العراق
يجب ان يتمتع بحس امني عالي حتى يحمي نفسه
ويحمي زملائه من ظروف العمل المحيطه
المعروفه يعني تعرفين انه دخلت الى بغداد
فقط القوات الامريكيه هو تحالف واسع فقط
القوات الامريكيه حدود 130 الف جندي
فتصوري حجم العمليات العسكريه كم هو واسع
وانهيار بلد في ايام معدوده
يعني حصل ارباك كبير
اهلا بكم مجددا مشاهدينا مراسلون ومصورون
وعاملون في مكتب العربيه في العراق فقدوا
ارواحهم او اصيبوا اصابات لا شفاء لها
طوال عقدين من الزمن في رحله البحث
المضنيه عن الخبر لكن العربيه لم تتوقف
يوما فالكلمه اشد وقعا من الرصاصه نتابعه
[موسيقى]
قتل سبعه اشخاص واصيب سته عشر اخرون بجروح
بينهم عدد من العاملين في قناه العربيه
مكاتب العربيه الواقعه في حي المنصور في
العاصمه العراقيه تتعرض لاول مره منذ
تاسيسها في بغداد لهجوم بسياره مفخخه
اننا فقدنا على الاقل ثلاثه من العاملين
في المحطه
ثلاثه او اربعه احد عشر شهيدا صحفيا خسرهم
مكتب قناه العربيه في العراق ففي الثامن
عشر من مارس عام 2004 خسر مكتب العربيه في
العراق اول شهيدين وهما المراسل علي
الخطيب والمصور الذي كان يرافقه علي عبد
العزيز بعد ان فتحت القوات الامريكيه
النار عليهما
تعددت اوصاف القوات الموجوده على ارض
العراق جواد كاظم العربيه بغداد
الصحفيون في العراق عرضه للاعتداء اليوم
كان موعد المراسل العربيه زميل جواد كاظم
ليواجهه الارهاب
كل انسان
عنده علاقه
بلحظه الموت قتل سبعه
اشهر اخرون بجروح بينهما عدد من العاملين
في قناه العربيه في انفجار سياره مفخخه
حيث تحولت المدن وشوارع العراقيه الى
[موسيقى]
صاحبها
اطول هل تسمعينه
[موسيقى]
شكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام اينما كنتم والى
لقاء اخر وضعيف وحوار خسرت قناه العربيه
مرسلتها في العراق الزميل اضافه الى
زميلين اخرين هما المصور عدنان خير الله
ومهندس الصوت خالد محمود
[موسيقى]
نبارك
لاداره قناه العربيه ولجمهور العربيه على
انطلاقتها قبل عشرين سنه
انا كنت من الناس
المتابعين لها منذ اليوم الاول لانطلاقتها
وكانت نقطه تحول في الاعلام العربي
المستقل
الاعلام الغير حكومي والغير بروتوكولي
والغير رسمي وكانت قيمه مضافه حقيقه
للاعلام العربي
جواد طبعا
رحم الله كل زملائنا
ولكن دائما نقول الحياه هي اقوى من رصاص
الظلام اريد ان استوقف اخبرتني بالامس
يعني الصدف ايضا تلعب دور انت اصبت ب
18/6/2005
وكريم ابنك الله يحفظ لك اياه خلق ب
18/6/2016 وبنفس الساعه وبنفس دقيقه
تقريبا اللي انا تعرضت بها
هل يمكن اعتبار انه انه دائما سنه الحياه
والفرح
ويعني الولاده من جديد شو فيها دائما
ستكون بواجه الظلاميين وبواجه رصاص
الاغتيال والذي لا يريد ان يسمع كلمه الحق
انه كل احنا اللي عايشين على قيد الحياه
محكومين بالقدر يعني
ومرسومه اقدارنا ومقاديرنا مرسومه
الانسان
مهما واجه من صعوبات عليه ان يستمر ان
يقدم ان يعمل ان ينتج ان اعتقد يريدون
يجيبون كريم
راح نتعرف كمان
من المدرسه اجا مباشره علي هذا
مباشره كريم كريم فخور كتير
عرف انه عندي نشره على الهواء وهذه قلت له
تعال حتى تصدق انه احنا خلف الكاميرا كان
موجود يعني ويراقب لا كريم بيك من اهم
الصحفيين وليس فقط يقرا على الورق انه من
يصنع الخبر على الارض كمان
عمليه الاغتيال نفس اليوم ونفس الساعه
وحتى نفس الدقيقه بالضبط
وان شاء الله تكون كل الحياه
مو حلوه thank you كريم اهلا وسهلا فيك
يلا يلا
والان نريد جواد ان ننتقل لدينا ننتقل الى
بغداد ايضا مع عبد الكريم عطان القياده في
تحالف تقدم استاذ عبد الكريم اهلا بك معنا
يعني
تحالف تقدم الى اي مدى من المهم ان يتفهم
السياسيون
وكل من يتعاطف في السياسه انه الصحافه هي
تنقل الخبر ولا يجب ان تكون الخبر وان
تستهدف
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم شكرا لك اخت ميسون
وشكرا لك اخ جواد وتحيه لقناتكم الكريمه
واقدم لكم ماسكه التهاني والتبريكات
بمناسبه مرور 20 عام على هذا الشاشه
العملاقه اللي نقلت معاناتها وماساتهم
ووصلت صوتهم وايضا اترحم على شهدائكم وهم
شهداء العراق وشهداء الامه العربيه وعلى
الاخت نجوى وعلى كل العاملين لانطوا
حياتهم من اجل ايصال كلمه الحق من خلال
هذه الشاشه وحقيقه احنا همينا يعني تعرضنا
لامور كثيره يعني احنا قسم من السياسيين
تعرفين تجرابك اني احترمها هذي الشاشه هي
والعربيه الحدث
ولانه الاعلام اعتقد اكثر من نوع يا اما
ممتاز او هادف او موجه
فاعلامكم اعلام هادف واعلام مهني وصل
الحقائق كما هي الى الناس نقل معاناه
الناس واتمنى ان يفهم الكل سواء كان
سياسيين او غير سياسيين انه انتم فقط
تنقلون الحقيقه والدافعون عن حقوق الناس
انتوا مالكم طرف لا بجانب سياسي ولا
بسياسه دوله ولا الى اخره ناس مهنيين
صحفيين طريقتكم انه تنقلون معاناه الناس
وصوت حر فاحييكم واحيي قناتكم
مالكين هذه القناه واتمنى لكم التوفيق
شكرا استاذ عبد الكريم اذا امكن توضح لنا
كم اسهم الاعلام بشكل عام
في بناء العمليه السياسيه في العراق خاصه
انه تعرف الانفتاح الاعلامي اللي اللي حدث
بالعراق بعد عام 2003 وتعدد وسائل القنوات
والصحوف والاذاعات
وانفتاحها بشكل كبير في العراق السؤال هو
كم اسهمت في تنظيج وبناء العمليه السياسيه
وانت سياسي
وقيادي في حركه تقدم
انت تعرف جنابك
انه
الاعلام
اصبح الان وهو يسمى كذلك السلطه الرابعه
وهذه السلطه ما بيها بدون رتوش تنقل
الحقائق كما هي يعني على سبيل المثال في
العربيه والعربيه الحدث نقلت ان معاناه
ناس قد يكون احنا ما نعرفهم حقيقه
احنا من خلال شاشتكم اتكلمنا على ملفات
مخيفه ومهمه ملفات فساد تدخل دول الجوار
الاسباب الاحتلال الامريكي مع اسي ما نتج
عنه امور كثيره والان هذه من خلال هاي
اللحظات المهمه
وتعرف جنابك قسم من القنوات الها مواقعنا
بها مشاهدين اكثر من قنواتهم ولكن قنوات
مثل قنواتكم ملايين المشاهدين يشوفونه من
خلالها ننقل معاناه الناس معاناه عنا
حقيقه لذلك اكو اكثر من ساحه للقتال
للقتال مو بالبندقيه القتال الصوت وحده من
ساحاتنا ووحده من ادواتنا هو ساحاتكم اللي
انتم
لا احنا ناخذ ولا انتم تاخذون حقيقه الامر
هي هاي المهنيه هو هذا صوت المهم عبد
الكريم عطان القياده في تحالف تقدم
نشكرك على المشاركه معنا اليوم
مشاهدينا منذ بدايات العربيه كان قدرها
تغطيه موسعه في مختلف في بلدان العالم
لاحداث لم ولم تنسى جهود كبيره بزلها
مراسلوها العربيه ولا يزالون
دائما
لتعرفوا اكثر نستذكر معكم هنا مع التغطيه
العربيه قبل نحو 20 عاما
[موسيقى]
يشهد عدد من المدن والمناطق الافغانيه
موجه من العنف المتقطع عشيه الانتخابات
التاريخيه
اضاف الملا عبيد في تسجيل صوتي حصلت عليه
العربيه لذلك فاننا لن نقبل هذه
الانتخابات كما يتعلق بنوعيه الحبر الذي
يصبغ به ابهام الناخبين
كسر رئيس الامريكي جورج بوش الامريكيين
على التفكير في مساله الامن
تتجه انظار العالم صوب الولايات المتحده
حيث يتوجهوا بعد ساعات اكثر من 100 مليون
ناخب امريكي الى صناديق الاقتراع
ولايه تكساس تعتبر معقلا ليس للجمهوريين
وحزب
[موسيقى]
دعا ابو مازن كافه الفصائل الفلسطينيه الى
التكاثف باستمرار عمل جميع الهيئات
القياديه في اطار السلطه الوطنيه الفحوص
التي اجريت حتى الان تستبعد وجود اي علامه
لسرطان على بعد امتار من هنا يرقدوا ابو
عمار مترنحا بين الحياه والموت
تحضيرا لدفن جثمان الرئيس الفلسطيني سر
عرفات مرحله تاريخيه جديده بدات برحيل
عرفات
[موسيقى]
ارتفعت حصيله الكارثه الطبيعيه التي ضربت
منطقه جنوب اسيا الى نحو عشره الاف قتيل
[موسيقى]
الزلزال الذي بلغت قوته 80 درجات فاصل
تسعه على مقياس
على انه خامس اقوى زلزال يضرب العالم
[موسيقى]
من الفوضى وتم سحب عدد كبير من هذه القرى
الذين حاولوا العوده الى مناطق المنكوكه
قرى كامله مدمره ومدن مشلوله تامه
الحصيله المرشحه لزياده كل ساعه تحدثت عن
مقتل ما لا يقل عن 30 الف شخص في سبع دول
[موسيقى]
جواد نحن سعدنا جدا بوجودك معنا شرفنا
نتمنى لك العمر المزيد
والبطوله شكرا واحبك للحياه الذي جعلك
تبني عائله الذكرى العشرين هي المزيد من
العمل المزيد من الانتاج مزيد من الابداع
في العربيه والى الامام باذن الله شكرا
اكيد تطيتنا دائما مشاهدينا مستمرا هذه
المره سننتقل الى استديوهاتنا في الرياض
لنتابع ايضا هذه الاحتفاليه بالعربيه
بعامها العشرين طبعا بالاضافه الى الاخبار
وملفات اخرى